every rock has a story to tell no matter
what kind of rock or where you find it
it preserves evidence of its history and
we can learn to decipher that history
take for example the Rock and the
Science Center lobby this piece of mica
schist now serving as a wall decoration
started its life long before the
dinosaurs it has undergone many changes
as it has travelled many miles both
horizontally and vertically over
hundreds of millions of years its story
starts about 450 million years ago on
the east coast of the proto North
American continent where rivers float
into the ocean the muddy sediment
carried by the rivers slowly settled out
in the quiet water beyond the waves over
hundreds of thousands of years more mud
was deposited every year gradually
accumulating to form a thick layer
during this time the Aptus ocean was
gradually decreasing in size because the
tectonic plate carrying the proto
african continent was converging with
the proto north american plate the
western leading edge of the proto
african plate bent down and subducted
underneath the eastern edge of the proto
north american plate the presence of a
deep oceanic trench along the subduction
zone allowed a great thickness of
sediments eroded from the proto north
american continent to accumulate the
increasing weight of overlying younger
sediments caused the mud to be compacted
and cemented into a fine-grained
sedimentary rock called shale eventually
the eye Aptus ocean floor was completely
subducting allowing proto africa to
collide with proto North America forming
the supercontinent of Pangea continents
have to lower density to be subducted so
consonant consonant collisions cause
intense deformation of the sedimentary
rocks caught in between our shale layer
was buried even deeper and folded like
an accordion this compression caused the
clay minerals in the shale to be rotated
into alignment perpendicular to the
compression and the higher temperature
at this depth caused the
Minerals to recrystallize into somewhat
larger mica grains forming a metamorphic
rock called slate clay minerals and
Myka's all have a crystal structure made
up of thin sheets of atoms that are
strongly bonded within each sheet but
have very weak bonds between each sheet
graphite has a very similar crystal
structure which is why it is used in
pencils when you write on a page with
one you brush off thin sheets of carbon
atoms when clay minerals and Myka's
become strongly aligned in a rock that
is squeezed the rock itself develops a
fine scale layering or foliation along
which it tends to break most easily much
like the pages in a book
thus the orientation of the foliation in
an ancient metamorphic rock preserves a
record of the plate compression
direction continued compression between
the two continents further deformed the
rocks it formed the very high ancestral
Appalachian Mountains and also formed
correspondingly deep roots this
deformation caused the slate to be
buried somewhat deeper where the
temperature was even greater this in
turn caused the mica grains to grow even
larger in size forming the sparkly
silver coloured muscovite we see today
and transforming the rock from a slate
into a mica schist after the Appalachian
Mountains reached about as high as the
present Himalayas the two continents
could not converge anymore and so the
mountains began to slowly erode about
200 million years ago there was a
reversal of place for adding directions
which caused the supercontinent of
Pangea to ripped apart and the present
atlantic ocean began to open the rift in
created valleys like the african rift
valleys of today and dinosaurs left
their footprints in the mud long lake
shores and present-day Connecticut in
Massachusetts the Appalachian Mountain
has continued to be eroded during this
time glaciers and rivers and landslides
gradually wore them down lower and lower
transporting sediments downhill and
ultimately depositing them in the
growing Atlantic Ocean as the mountain
peaks were lowered by erosion the total
mass above ground decreased to
compensate for this the mountain roots
rose buoyantly upward just like an
iceberg that melts on the top that is
replenished by the buoyant rise of its
route thus over tens of millions of
years the once deeply buried mica schist
was passively uplifted closer and closer
to the Earth's surface
the schist was finally exposed at the
surface within the recent Pleistocene
Ice Age when ice sheets originating in
northern Canada scraped south across New
England multiple times and then only
very recently a geologist found the mica
schist in New Hampshire so get back to
brown and put together it's amazing
story